do you remember wingdings
that uh weird font that was oddly
popular in the 90s
have you ever wondered why font like
that would even exist
well as it turns out it's possible to
build a font family made of images and
icons rather than letters now icon fonts
provide a fantastic option for the
little images and icons that often
decorate websites
there's an icon font i like called
social this front is free and open
source so i could download it and serve
it from my site
however the font is publicly available
from the font site itself so i'll use
that instead
let's see it in action notice that i've
added some shadow to the font icons this
file looks a bit complex so bear with me
here's what's going on
the icon font characters are added using
the css before selector i've added some
formatting to that as well including css
text shadow now that rule is applied to
every element whose class name begins
with social
and you can see that each of the list
items has a class with a name made up of
social and a brand name
now at the top you'll see an at import
rule that points to an external css file
let's look at that now the at font face
rule at the top of this gives the source
of the actual font files and there's
some variations available there and what
you see below that are selectors based
on the class names like the ones we've
used social flicker those who laughed at
him and so on for example set the class
social flicker on an element and the
character f will be displayed before it
which in the social font is the flicker
logo clever huh
icon fonts have a number of advantages
over plain old images they're vector
graphics that can be infinitely scaled
and an entire set of images can be
downloaded in one font and this makes
them a great potential solution for
responsive designs where you require
minimum downloads and maximum
scalability
now if you look at the resources
required for the we love icon fonts site
you can see that the total weight for
the hundreds of images from all the
fonts on the page is less than 300k
icon fonts have a number of advantages
over plain old images they're vector
graphics that can be infinitely scaled
an entire set of images can be
downloaded in one font
this makes them a great potential
solution for responsive designs where
you require minimum downloads and
maximum scalability the example here
shows lots of different options for icon
fonts
and of course the characters in icon
fonts behave just like letters in other
fonts so you can resize and color them
and use other css effects
just like you would with text
there are lots of tools for creating
icon fonts and lots of pre-built icon
fonts check out the links below the
video there's also a link to information
about improving accessibility by using
aria attributes